new year new decade and a new season of
IQ of everything no after this
obligatory intro
so what exactly do you need to know for
the future seasons the first major thing
that you should probably keep in mind
going into season four is at the end of
season three Kageyama was invited to the
national youth training camp we don't
know what that entails or if he even
goes but we can assume that there's
gonna be some sort of reference to that
in season four going into the spring
inter-high tournament nekima and kokuto
donnie hi are both massive threats and
kata suno hasn't had any meaningful
success against them while they were at
the training camp in Tokyo we can assume
both will eventually face cata suno at
some point and those will be some big
matches especially the nekima match
because they're still considered Cod as
soon as longtime rival and one of the
two teams play against each other it's
known as the Battle of the garbage dump
also cada suno has never beaten nekima
high in an official match even when the
Little Giant was on their team so
that'll be a first for them speaking of
nekima high you also need to remember
that in one of the OVA s they got a new
player named Lev hiya
he was really an experienced at the time
but we see in season two that he's
improving at a crazy rate so if they
face against each other he's gonna be a
problem that they have to address as for
Pagano Donny hi they have the fifth best
ace in the country in Qatar o Boko who
has proven in the training camp that he
is also a massive threat as long as he
doesn't get tilted which brought this
quote-unquote
emo move Daichi still has potential to
make some moves on his wife boo ue Misha
Mia I want to see my boy get in there
and make things happen this season I'm
sick of there being only one love
interest in the show well su Kashima and
Daichi were the only ones to sustain
injuries in the show which likely won't
lead to anything but the more you know
her it's a character development we're
gonna start with like Hinata in Kageyama
like the driving force behind kind of
Sunnah everything that makes the show
interesting and then we're gonna work
our way down to the Yamaguchi's of the
show that show up once every 10 episodes
I want to play coach Hinata has picked
up a lot of new skills and tricks such
as you know the faints and the quick
variations and learning the white from
koto in season two was really helpful
there's also the training arc in season
two where he works with ek practicing at
different tempos and with different
setters so that you know he's not
completely reliant on Kageyama
Akiyama doesn't really get too many new
skills because he's already like the
prodigy on the team so he
got everything pretty down pat we're
pretty sure everybody understands the
character development the relationship
between Kageyama and Hinata up until
this point so instead I'm gonna talk
about their quick and the development of
the quick which is their special move
that they used to beat everybody the
first iteration they discovered it on
accident paga yama basically puts the
ball because he's like a prodigy where
it needs to go and Hinata
smacks us into the ground right Hinata
is completely reliant on Kageyama he
can't even open his eyes because if he
does then he like overthinks it I don't
know he closes his eyes that's a point
there's no real thought process behind
him so they make the normal quick which
is slightly slower but he actually can
see what he's doing and then he does
this thing or whatever so they have the
Freak quick and the normal quick and
then in the second season they want to
introduce this new idea of Hinata
opening his eyes during the free quick
and everybody's pretty much against it
because they don't think that you can
possibly perceive what's happening in
that amount of time cuz it's so fast so
then the coaches like subconsciously
thinking okay well he's the ginger you
can't do it by himself so he goes
through Cagayan I need you to stall the
ball right where he not is gonna hit it
so he doesn't need to think because
apparently this kid thinks he's gonna
actually play bro you want me to stall
the what after a fistfight and a whole
bunch of training they eventually get it
decent it's progressing second one and
the character progression is Daiichi oh
I kind of like this character nobody
really appreciates him that is until you
know he like gets injured and then
they're like oh no do you other captains
really good too and so they made an
episode about him or whatever I don't
know cool character estas aqui they
really beat me I should quit volleyball
for a bit and make his scene I don't
know he's kind of he's kind of baited in
terms of development the only thing that
he really works on throughout the show
is just his serving which is then we
have Ryu nosegay and nishinoya who are
like the horny duo and the comedy relief
of the show you know oh Sh
he should know is just a cool character
pretty minimal development they do
mention him working on his setting so
that he can be a little bit more
versatile in the core but aside from
that not too much to mention do we ever
you know say who is the left wing Spiker
play he doesn't really do anything he
likes gets random
scenes where he scores but I mean
everybody gets those scenes off the
court he's funny is the comedy relief
which is cool but on the court okay
you're just yep you're another player
got it
sugawara is like the other upperclassmen
in the sense that he doesn't really see
a lot of character development mostly
just because he got replaced by Kageyama
so he doesn't play a whole lot they did
briefly mention in season 3 that he had
been working on his spiking but it
wasn't anything too big to be fair the
story doesn't really focus on the
upperclassman's development or so how
they're influencing Kageyama and Hinata
going forward Fukushima is a dick I
don't want to try oh why don't you want
to try suka Shima what happened to your
brother su Kashima he wasn't a starter
he's starting to apply himself more now
that we're getting further into the
series man there's some progression with
him in Takayama slowly starting to get
along with one another so we'll see if
that trend continues into the new season
we're gonna wrap up the character
development section with Yamaguchi what
do you say about this carrot is he a
good character
[Music]
is there room for improvement yeah I'd
say there's a lot of development that he
could make yeah they just really like to
drive home with these characters how
useless they are and then they have like
that one episode no no he's not useless
and it's like bro and have you been
watching this show up until this point
of course he's useless the development
for the character is good just because
there's so much room to improve so you
could have a field day with everything
that he could work on oh now he's
practicing this because he doesn't do
anything his entire development is about
his jump low serve you he also has a
history of struggling with his nerves
but he demonstrates against Albus Joe
sigh and the semi-finals that he's
starting to get better at managing his
nerves and delivering when it counts I
could go over the side characters too I
could I you know he toca getting a
little bit more outspoken who cares so
that should give you a solid foundation
to go into the new season with I have no
idea what happens in the next season so
I try to cover what I thought would be
relevant but if you feel like I could
have done something better or I missed
something important I probably did and I
accept that about myself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]